ha sido una reunión extraordinaria
marcada por el hermetismo para intentar
superar el impase generado entre el
gobierno de Colombia y la guerrilla del
eln luego que el pasado 31 de diciembre
el presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
anunciara públicamente un cese al fuego
bilateral que se extendería por los
próximos seis meses y que tres días
después fue desmentido por la guerrilla
del eln en esta oportunidad el encuentro
se lleva a cabo en el hotel eurobilding
en el este de Caracas Y aunque no hubo
convocatoria a la prensa se pudo ver a
representantes de ambas delegaciones por
los pasillos del Hotel el presidente de
la federación colombiana de ganaderos
José Félix laforí quien forma parte de
la delegación del gobierno colombiano
respondió algunas inquietudes a la
prensa dijo que las conversaciones iban
bastante bien que no veía razones para
que se pudiese suspender el segundo
ciclo de conversaciones que iniciaría en
México la segunda semana de febrero
específicamente el 13 y que este
encuentro respondía a la necesidad que
tenía la delegación del eln de escuchar
los argumentos del gobierno colombiano
tras el impase en esta oportunidad Se
confirmó también la presencia de
representantes de los países garantes
como Venezuela Cuba y Noruega se espera
que las conversaciones se extiendan
hasta este viernes y posteriormente se
emita un comunicado conjunto sobre los
resultados del encuentro